which of the following real numbers are
rational now for a number to be rational
it means that it can be expressed as the
ratio of two integers so for example the
number two is rational because it can be
expressed as two over 1.
now let's see which of these can be
expressed as the ratio of two integers
so we have 0.3737
this is the same thing as 3737
ten thousandths so we can write it
literally as 3737
over
10
over 10 thousands these two are
equivalent i've just restated this as
the ratio of two integers so this is
this is rational check
12 over 31 what's already expressed as
the ratio of two integers so this also
is rational
square root of 11.
so the square root of any non-perfect
square is going to be irrational and 11
definitely is not a perfect square so
this right over here is not going to be
a rat it's not going to be rational or
we would say that it is irrational
0.44444
so in general any decimal that's
terminating and this is terminating
because you only have a finite number of
fours here you have six of them you have
a bunch but you have only six or even if
you just kept repeating forever so
something that keeps repeating on and on
and on forever all of those can be
converted to a ratio of integers and
this one in particular this is the same
thing as four four four hundred forty
four thousand 444
over
over 1 million
over 1 million in fact if you were to
say this this is 444
444
millionths that they have right over
here but i've just expressed it as the
ratio of two integers so this right over
here is definitely
rational
now here i have 2 plus square root of 8.
if i just had 2 by itself well 2 is 2
over 1 that would be rational but if i'm
adding a rational to something that is
irrational then the combination is going
to be irrational and the square root of
8 is irrational 8 is not a perfect
square so this one right over here is
not rational or irrational
now let me be clear this is not rational
so we would call it irrational so the
three real numbers that are rational are
this one this one and this one